[Music]
germany's highest mountain that
zugspitze has just opened for the winter
season under special coronavirus
restrictions
only people who are fully vaccinated or
recovered from the illness have access
to the slopes
i'm wearing gloves ski goggles and a
face mask so i feel quite protected
the rules up here
also apply in other parts of germany
where you need to be either vaccinated
or recovered to attend a concert or
visit a restaurant or shopping mall
there's a growing support for making
vaccines mandatory nearly 70 percent of
germans back such a move they believe
stricter rules are necessary to break
the fourth wave which threatens to break
the country's health care system
welcome today germany set a tragic new
record more than a hundred thousand
people have now died of covet 19.
meanwhile the infection rate is going
through the roof 76 000 new cases were
reported within just one day
pandemic fatigue and too many who refuse
to take the vaccine are forcing germany
and its neighbor austria to adopt
stricter measures too little too late
vienna is preparing for a festive season
but will this be the happy christmas so
many are hoping for
a drastic rise in covet 19 infection
numbers has cast a dark cloud over the
weeks to come
the austrian government felt compelled
to act
it initially introduced a lockdown for
unvaccinated people allowing them only
to leave their homes for certain
essential purposes
some say this was just a way of forcing
people to get vaccinated under another
guys
others question whether the lockdown can
be effective
it could work if it were very fireball
but it's unlikely to be the case it's
hard to put into practice
we came by subway i'm not even sure if
they check there no nobody up till now
over the past two days nobody checked me
and i was also in shopping centers
having more people vaccinated could ease
the situation in hospitals already
working at maximum capacity this is one
of more than 10 vaccination centers in
vienna
here you can get your first second or
third jab without needing an appointment
and suddenly more people are keen to do
so
in austria about 64 percent of the
population are fully vaccinated that's
one of the lowest rates in western
europe and it's not high enough to stop
the surge
a lot of people need to be vaccinated
now for their everyday lives for their
job or for private things to go out for
a meal in the evening to go to the
cinema and that's why we're seeing a
significant increase in vaccinations
but most of the people here have come
for a second or third jab only around 20
percent are getting their first shot and
that percentage has to increase experts
say to turn the tide
dr catherine schmitz is a behavioral
economist and psychologist at the
cluster of excellence the politics of
inequality at constance university and
the tour gao institute of economics and
she joins us now good to have you with
us i know that you studied people's
attitude towards getting vaccinated
already since the beginning of the
pandemic and you found that compulsory
vaccination actually reduces people's
willingness to get vaccinated how come
why is that
yes it's important to notice that we
studied people's agreement with being
like united not very compliant so we ask
whether people are okay with being like
me that you get vaccinated because you
are forced to but you don't want to and
this is what we what we study
and why are people more happy being
vaccinated if it is voluntary than
enforced well two important reasons is
the lack of autonomy people strive for
autonomy we know everyone who has
children has this experience and yeah
and mandates restrict autonomy and the
other
uh reason is moral dis engagement so
people feel morally obliged to do the
right thing to get vaccinated for
example but if the government takes this
responsibility this crowds out the
feeling of moral responsibility
now we could say well we are
okay but we've been we've been we've
been in in situations similar situations
before uh and there was compulsory
vaccination when it came to smallpox uh
that was uh accepted in in west germany
right up until to
1976. so why is it a no-go now when it
comes to kovit-19
so the vacuum is new there is a new
method the mrna method so people are
unsure about long-term effects that's a
different situation but maybe um with
the smallpox it mainly hurts children
and with covet mainly older people are
at risk
risk and in germany we have the not so
nice situation that
older people are not so well integrated
in the families and maybe yeah people
would care more about their children
about than about the elderly
of course there's this this big
discussion about the legality now in the
year 2021 when it comes to
making vaccination compulsory uh if we
just take a quick look
at the most quoted paragraph in german
law for our viewers to better understand
because the basic law for the federal
republic of germany article 2 says one
everyone has the right to the free
development of his personality provided
that he does not infringe on the rights
of others and i too everyone has the
right to life and physical integrity the
freedom of the person is inviolable
it goes on then but basically the
problem is that that
it gives to it gives both sides
the argument that they need saying it's
my personal decision
or saying
no it's not your personal decision
because unvaccinated people are a danger
to others
that's a dilemma how likely is it that
people who are not vaccinated
can still be convinced
so according to our data it is quite
likely we find that on less than five
percent are consistently opposed to
voluntary vaccination over all the
pandemic all the others changed their
mind so there is a lot of dynamics going
on in vaccination attitudes by the way
this hardcore of resistance is much
larger in case of enforcement but there
is room for persuasion people act upon
their beliefs so we see that beliefs
about vaccinations change
and
the important beliefs to change are the
belief in the effectiveness of the
vaccine
trust and government and the idea
whether an enforced vaccination
restricts your freedom or one could say
on the other hand if everyone gets
vaccinated maybe due to enforcement it
increases everyone's freedom
how big a role does history play i've
done some research and national
socialist opposed uh were opposed to
vaccination anti-semitism played a role
there uh compulsory vaccination on the
other hand was normal in the former east
german state the the gdr
where today we see a particularly high
number of anti-vaxxers that's
interesting
yes we have data which are a bit
counter-intuitive maybe at first glance
so we see that older east germans who
have experienced themselves the coercive
regime of east germany are less opposed
to
vaccination mandates and overall to
mandates with respect to covet policies
which have parallels with their own
experience in the gdr like travel
restrictions also
and they are less opposed in the case of
mandates than older east west germans of
the same age
now um
of course we observe the different
vaccination rates in the two places and
there is another layer which is support
for the afd so even before the pandemic
young east germans felt left behind in
germany and there was a lot of support
for the afd which also supports the
anti-covet demonstrations so there's
another process going on
all right so
a lot of issues there at play uh but
thank you so much dr catherine schmelz
from the concert university and the togo
institute of economics for explaining it
to us thank you time now for one of your
questions over to derrick williams
what is the likelihood of sas cove 2
becoming seasonal and endemic
i'd say
pretty much every expert of note now
believes
it's kind of inevitable but to explain
why
uh we need some definitions first
covid19 is currently a pandemic an
infectious disease
affecting people on a worldwide scale
and as we've learned yet again here in
europe in the last few weeks
with very unpredictable fluctuations
that we call waves
with endemic diseases
numbers of people being infected and
landing in hospitals are fairly constant
in populations over time enough so
that we can at least ballpark predict
patterns of transmission like we can for
instance with seasonal flu
it's an endemic disease that we know
will generally affect more people in the
wintertime and we can broadly forecast
how many which
helps us to manage it to some extent
no one really knows yet how long it'll
take covet 19 to reach that status
because it'll depend on a range of
factors the number one factor
is how many people acquire at least some
immunity to it which involves
either getting infected by the virus or
vaccinated against it and how long lived
that protection proves to be
is another big part of the puzzle um
vaccine distribution and take-up
varies widely in countries across the
world so experts say
that pandemic numbers won't stabilize
everywhere at the same time but
at some point in the future
after enough people acquire some immune
protection to source kobe 2 through
infection
or vaccination
and barring the appearance of aggressive
new variants of course
researchers think
that covid19 will begin to affect
more predictable numbers of us every
year
at somewhat predictable intervals um
like with seasonal flu which strikes
hardest in winter
when people spend a lot more time
indoors
[Music]
and a quick look to latin america where
military doctors and nurses protested in
peru against where they allege a
dangerous conditions that are leaving
them vulnerable to kobe 19. they rallied
in the capital lima the protesters say
the government isn't giving them
sufficient protective equipment or
medical facilities they say they're
forced to treat covet patients alongside
other patients increasing the risk of
cross-infection
that's all for this edition of our kobit
19 special from me and the team as
always thanks for watching stay safe
stay healthy